joining us now with reaction is the
former assistant secretary of the
treasury monica crowley along with fox
news contributor joe koncha thank you
both for joining us uh uh monica i want
to talk uh mostly about the economy
because that affects everybody but for
the president of the united states to
personally pick up the phone and talk to
a nurse at a hospital to do a favor for
a friend
i i don't know how that strikes most
people but if i'm in that waiting room
and somebody's getting preferential
treatment because they're a buddy of
joe's
i i it seems odd to me
this is your ruling class in action
always with a point of privilege right
it was very weird for joe biden to blurt
that out and make that admission because
it made him look really bad i mean we
are still in the middle of a pandemic
and people are struggling and he's
saying hey look i i
elbowed my friend and his wife to the
front of the line
i also would love to know how many
people in that particular hospital
system have been laid off or fired
because they refused the facts therefore
creating a huge backlog due to short
staffing
yeah and joe look the president tried to
put a big spin on uh the jobs numbers
because they were horrific they were
nowhere close to where they were
supposed to be but part of the problem
in the white house is you've got joe
biden and kamala harris they're both
poor communicators and they never take
any questions and then when they do talk
off script you get something like this
which causes its own uproar
it's the worst messaging i've seen jason
and you know you could go back and study
this stuff in the modern political era
and and to blame kovid as jen saki did
it's like it's all they have did did
kovad force us to withdraw from
afghanistan in the disastrous way that
we did of course not is covet causing
the border to be wide open we're
actually covered positive migrants are
flooding into the country of course not
is coveted causing skyrocketing crime in
american cities of course not it's
coveted causing skyrocketing inflation
of course not and and and thanks of
all these lies and that's the proper
word to use here lies that that the
president and his chief handlers like
saki have tried to sell the american
people like in august job creation
missed expectations by 500 000 jobs a
half million in september it missed by
another three hundred thousand and there
the president is out there saying the
job report shows progress that is gas
sizing the gaslighting with with
dynamite marinated in kerosene he also
claimed that 3.5 trillion in spending
cost 0.0 dollars that it will somehow
cut taxes while inflation is almost sure
to continue rising that it will reduce
the debt all lies and for anyone with
ears eyes and a halfway functional brain
these arguments are about the best
unintentional comedy you'll hear except
the president is as serious as a heart
attack when he is making them and this
is where we are now at this point you're
right about the messaging it is it is
lying and it is deceptive and it is
intentional
now monica you've been up close and
personal with the white house along the
way i mean part of the problem is you
have a kamala harris who's nowhere to be
seen she's just literally flying to
palm springs when they're trying to do
uh you know critical things with the
united states congress but the cabinet's
nowhere i mean we've we've got this
major problem with shipping off the
shores you've got uh offload of ship
shipments that are coming into these
ports and no trucks to go underneath
these containers where's pete buda judge
i mean at their cabinet is pretty well
absent from the discussion
well their labor secretary was out today
to talk about this abysmal jobs report
and trying to spin it as was the
president but overall jason you're
exactly right look the vice president
wants as much diff distance between
herself and these catastrophes as
possible she's trying to preserve her
own political viability so whether it
comes to the economy or the border or
the whole array of things that joe biden
has given to her for her plate
she doesn't want to deal with it she is
not out there publicly in fact the
latest video she was talking to some
kids about space exploration which is
not exactly on the top of most americans
lists of things
but the rest of the cabinet you're
exactly right they have high-tailed it
away from all of these controversies
they know that this presidency is in
free fall they can see the president's
poll numbers cratering and now you even
have the press at least some of them
starting to report on the faltering
economy and some of these other things
because they can't ignore it but make no
mistake when the press reports this
stuff like for example cnn today talking
about how bad these jobs numbers are
they're not doing it because they want
to see joe biden fail they're doing it
as a warning to the white house that
they better start getting their act
together particularly on the economy
because most americans do vote on
kitchen table issues
yeah and joe nothing says hey let's uh
let's fight inflation by throwing a few
trillion dollars into the economy and
and spend more by government i mean i i
don't know where they're at with their
messaging on this but that is not the
remedy to solve the problems that are
ahead of us
yeah a little removed from econ 101 but
but i'm pretty sure that if you print
3.5 trillion dollars of new money and
put it into the economy that may devalue
the dollar a little bit and and we're
already at a 30-year high on core
inflation so if this spending bill gets
passed and even if it gets shaved down
what do you think is going to happen to
the economy to monica's point that's
what people vote on first but but three
big takeaways from the president's polls
uh when you peel away the onion all
right so republicans are overwhelmingly
against the president of course
democrats
about 80 percent are still with him so
they kind of cancel each other out i
always look at independence jason
because they're the people that decide
elections in
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin ohio
georgia so on 32 percent of americans
approve of this president less than one
in three think about that that's just
nine months into office that's that
that's a hockey season and a solid
majority of voters now believe the
administration as a whole jason is not
competent running the government that's
a very difficult impression to undo but
finally on the economy he is polling
below 40 percent on the border in
afghanistan he's polling in the 20s
crime is a huge issue as well is it more
expensive to live in this country yes is
it less safe yes is the border secured
no is afghanistan a threat with the
re-emergence of al-qaeda in isis yes you
tell me how he's going to fix those four
big issues when he's never communicating
outside of a teleprompter it ain't going
to happen unless somebody else is doing
the communicating i guess that's jen
saki who is now the face of this
administration congratulations
yeah that that is core to the problem is
joe biden and kamala harris have bad
judgment but they're also poor
communicators uh monica crowley john joe
koncha thank you both for joining us
tonight